here are the nominees for achievement in
cinematography Matthew Liberty for Black
Swan wally pfister or inception Danny
Cohen for The King's Speech
Jeff Cronin with' for the social network
Roger Deakins for True Grit these
envelopes are works of art in themselves
this Oscar goes to wally pfister for
inception
this is the first Academy Award and
fourth nomination for wally pfister
good god what have you done thank you so
much this is a phenomenal honor for me
thank you the Academy for this great
honor and for the respect that you've
shown for all cinematographers ah to
take a breath here for a minute
breathe it in for a second hey was
where's that thing that shows you how
much time you know there goes okay
anyway none of what I did was would have
been possible without the incredible
vision of my master Christopher Nolan
his work you're taking on my time
his work has inspired me for 12 years
and continues to he's a brilliant
filmmaker as we all know much thanks to
Emma Nolan to Warner Brothers to my
fantastic Union crew and to my family
and I'm Nick Klara Mia it's my mom and
dad thanks so much